>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Well,
good afternoon, everyone,
and welcome to the African
and Middle East Division.
I'm Mary-Jane Deeb Chief of the
division, and I'm really very,
very happy to see you all here
for this special presentation
with Israeli artist Avner Moriah who
will talk to us about his new book
"From Text to Image:
Illumination as Visual Commentary".
I hope it will not be
only about the new book,
that it'll be about more than that.
As most of you already
know, our division,
and this is my little commercial for
our division because we're webcast,
and we want the world to know
where this event is taking place.
So, our division is made
up of three sections.
The Hebraic section, of
course, the African section,
and the Near East section.
We're responsible for materials
from 78 countries around the world,
from the near east,
central Asia, the Caucasus,
as well as from the
entire continent of Africa.
And, of course, for Hebraic, we
collect from around the world.
We're very active in acquiring
and developing our collections,
greeting visitors coming from
countries from our regions,
and organizing programs,
symposia, workshops.
We're also have exhibits and special
displays, and we had a big one,
a big exhibit on the Hebrew
book a few years ago which was,
which brought in hundreds of
thousands of people to see some
of the treasures that we hold here.
We are particularly happy to have
Avner Moriah here with us today.
Not only because we
like to invite scholars
to discuss their productions,
their creations, their books
and how they use the materials in
the collections, in our collection,
other collections, to write their
works or to produce their books,
but we are happy because
Avner Moriah's works,
his illustrations,
focus on the Bible.
And, the Hebraic section's holdings
are especially strong in the areas
of the Bibles, or the
Bible and rabbinic liturgy
and Hebrew language and literature.
The section is also expanding its
collection of modern artist books
on the Bible, and so it is fitting
to have Avner Moriah come and talk
to us about his journey through
the Bible, and how he became
such an illustrious artist.
We hold his beautifully
illustrated book of Genesis
and have just acquired
his most recent.
>> Don't give it away.
>> Okay. I won't.
I'm stopping here.
I've been stopped,
so I do not continue.
Okay. So, we will surprise you.
I think, put it this way.
We will surprise you, okay,
with a display of his books,
of his illustrated books and
also of some of our treasures,
some of our older Bibles, some of
the unique Bibles that we hold.
So, that will be a surprise
at the end of the program.
And now, Dr. Ann Brener, the Hebrew
specialist in the Hebraic section,
will introduce our
speaker for today.
[ Inaudible Conversation
and Laughter ]
>> Ann Brener: I'm sorry.
That just kind of popped out.
It is a surprise.
[laughs] The Bible has been a
constant focus of creativity
through the ages, inviting scholars,
poets, artists, and dreamers to fill
in the gaps, flesh out the details,
and delve into the meanings.
Today's speaker is
one of those artists,
and today's display a tribute to his
unique vision of a biblical text.
Avner Moriah is one
of the best known
and widely collected
artists in Israel today.
He is what we call in
Hebrew a [Hebrew language].
He's a national treasure.
He is a Jerusalem artist
who was born in Jerusalem.
He lives and works in Jerusalem, but
his works have reached every corner
of the globe and they grace
the finest of collections,
the Metropolitan Museum of Art,
the Israel Museum in Jerusalem,
the Art Institute of
Boston, and many, many more.
Here in the Library of
Congress, we also collect him,
and indeed his illuminated book
of Genesis as Dr. Deeb just said,
it has long been one of our
favorite showpieces here
in the Hebraic section.
We have a special surprise
for you today.
Now, I'll say it.
As you know, there will be a
display following today's talk,
and you will be able to see
some really gorgeous examples
of Avner's work together
with some rare editions
of the biblical texts
that have inspired him.
But, what you don't know
because we didn't know
until yesterday ourselves, was
that we're also going to be able
to display, I think for the first
time in America, his new book,
his next book in his biblical
journey, the book of Exodus.
It is absolutely gorgeous, and
it's on display for you afterwards.
So, we're so delighted
that worked out.
It was due to the generosity
of the Coven Family Endowment
that we were able to make
this really extravagantly
beautiful purchase.
And, I'm delighted to have
the opportunity to thank them.
I also want to thank the Ms. Golina
Teverovski [assumed spelling]
in Acquisitions Division who
worked some kind of magic
in getting this book straight from
the binding and into the shelves
of the Library of Congress
in record time,
just in time for today's display.
So, thanks to Golina.
Are you here, Golina?
No? Well, she deserves our thanks.
All great stories seem to begin with
a quest, and today we are privileged
to welcome Avner Moriah into our
reading room and hear firsthand
about his own journey
through the Bible.
So, please join me in
welcoming Avner Moriah.
[ Applause ]
>> Avner Moriah: Thank
you for having me.
It's a great honor to be here,
and going to put my watch here
so I make sure that we keep
the time schedule right.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
I'm going to take you through a
quick journey through my work,
and then we will concentrate
on the project
that I'm working on right now.
Actually, I've been working on it
for the last 15 years is
"Illuminating the Text".
I didn't start as an illustrator,
but I came about this project
from painting the Israeli
landscape and other things.
So, I'm going to give you a quick
run of how I go to where I go.
So, what you see here is
works of mine from '78.
I was a student at Bazalel.
I, I'm a graduate of
Bazalel Academy of Art,
and Yale University
MFA program there.
These are landscapes that I
painted in the Judean hills.
This is a series that I did on
Israeli soldiers in the landscape.
With [inaudible] of camouflage
behind it that what got me to work
on the subsequent was
the idea of camouflage.
This, I did a large
series on the holocaust,
and what inspired me there
was the movie "Shoah".
My dear, with this subject matter is
usually we paint either the victims
or the perpetrators, and
I chose to paint both
because by putting the perpetrators
and the victims together in one,
on one canvas extends the
horror that actually took place.
I, whenever I do a
series of paintings,
I tend to go and do
serious research.
I went to Germany to look at the
works, the German expressionist work
that was done before the war,
and you can really sense
that the war is coming.
So, this is my stadium.
This is the dining hall.
This is a series that I did on the
expulsion of the Jews from Spain.
Again, I went to Spain and looked
at the art that was done in Spain,
and what was interesting
that right around 1492,
you see a tremendous
amount of search
in the churches that
were all renovated.
And so, when you come to think about
it, it was either from money or gold
that came from South America or
money that came from the Muslims
or the Jews where the
church said to them,
"Prove to us that you're good
members of the community."
So, this is looting the synagogue.
For years, I've been painting
the Israeli landscape.
This is the Mount Sinai.
I actually went to paint
next to Mount Sinai,
and I have a small
anecdote about it.
It is but when I stood and painted
there, in order to get to the point
that I wanted to paint, you
had to pass an Egyptian post,
and there was an officer
that was standing there.
And, for five days, he let me go.
After five days, he
wanted baksheesh.
But the Bedouins came to him
and said, "He's a good painter.
Let him paint."
So, I didn't have to pay anything.
So, that's just like a
nice human interaction.
These are all landscapes
that I paint on site.
These are large canvases.
They're 42 inches by 80 inches.
This is a sunset over the Sea
of Galilee with a Khamsin winds.
These are views of Jerusalem.
I'll just go quickly
through it so we can get
to the point where I want to.
This is a painting of my wife.
She passed away five years ago.
She was the inspiration
of my Bible project,
the one that I'm working on now.
What got me into dealing with the
Jewish text was an opportunity
that I got from JPS.
I did two large murals for them.
The first one that you see here is,
I did a big project on the gathering
at Mount Sinai, and when we
looked for a place to do my mural
at the JPS, they said,
"Find any place
that you want in the building."
So, I chose the staircase
that leads to the library,
and I thought of places that
we go up and down in the bible.
And, I thought of Mount
Sinai because at Mount Sinai,
we got the written
word and the, also.
So, and there are other cases
of going up and down the ladder,
like Joseph in the
pit or Jacob's ladder.
The number ten occurred
because we have the ten plagues
and the ten commandments.
I thought of the ten Rabbis that
were executed by the Romans and the,
and I thought also of ten
[inaudible] that dealt
with the gathering at Mount Sinai.
So, the centerpiece is the different
times that we went, that Moses goes
up and down the mountain.
I mean, there's more than one
story about getting the Torah.
And, the other panels around
are the different points
that I just mentioned.
And, after I finished these murals,
people came to me and said, "Oh,
you should do a Haggadah.
You should do a Haggadah,
now, so I just finished the.
So, this actually worked,
coincided with the first round
of my wife battling cancer, and I
thought of the Passover Haggadah
because we all go in
and out of Egypt.
And, this is one of the pages
that Jerusalem is the
center of the universe.
Actually, here, it's
interesting because the image
that I used was a painting
from Piero della Francesca,
"Resurrection of Christ",
and the resurrection
also deals with Passover.
This is, again, an image
from the Passover Haggadah.
When I, when I did these series, I
worked, again, very methodically.
I did the many, many
drawings, many, many studies,
and then I sit together
with my calligrapher.
I'm totally dyslexic, so I don't
even come close to writing text
because the letters
have their own life.
So, we design page after
page with my images,
and I do everything twice.
I first do the preliminary studies,
and then I sit with the calligrapher
and we design page after
page with text and image.
These are images, after I finish
this, I have a friend in New York.
She is a curator of a museum.
She said, "Oh, you should
do something more cheerful.
How about doing some work about
[Hebrew language]" Like, tales.
So, so, I thought of the
scroll of Esther because it's,
she thought more like
Hansel and Gretel
than stories like that, but I chose.
And so, again, I went
and I studied the tale
of Esther or the scroll of Esther.
And, I created 76 images where
I paint the visual story.
I think one of the gifts
that I've been given
from whoever gives those gifts is
my ability to, when I read a text,
to come up with a set design.
That's why I showed you my
other works to see how I create
like a set design from
something that is abstract,
but if you give me very few details,
I can come with my own design so,
and I work, again,
here very methodically.
I looked at Persian
miniatures, Indian miniatures,
and I always make a point
about making that I live
and work in the Middle East.
So, although you could see
that there's a three dimension,
but I also use the two
dimension design even
in my holocaust paintings.
When I did them, I, there
are three ideas that I had.
One is called "The Dance of Death".
That's a Nordic theme that
deals with mass killings.
And, it was during the 100 year war
between the Protestants
and the Catholics.
Also, there's a theme in Italian
southern theme that is called
"The Massacre of the Innocents".
They actually painted the
destruction of the temple.
And then, I paint, I
thought of Egyptian art
because they deal with
life after death.
And, I combined all
these images together
to create my own interpretation
of the text.
It didn't make sense at the time
to try and copy any of the visuals
that you know the horrific
photographs,
but to come up with my own, so
to speak, hell that described
that period of our people.
And, when you think about it,
you know, we have horrors going
on right now around the world,
and yet, we keep on our life as,
you know, wherever we live,
we keep our life as it is.
So, these images are I took
from Persian miniatures,
and I also looked at the, like the
guys at the bottom getting drunk,
I thought of Bruegel and
his guys getting drunk.
The dancers, I picked
from Indian miniatures.
Bringing Esther to the palace, I
thought of these carriages that were
in France in the 1600s where they
were carrying their princesses
or in China to the palace.
So, these are the drunks
from Bruegel.
These are the dancers.
These are the horses.
Can see the dancers again.
The image I used, this is
from an Indian miniatures.
I used the images of Susa,
the capital of Persia.
And, these are Muslim
miniatures that I looked at.
You'll see when I get to my
scroll of Esther, this is Vermeer.
Vermeer always has a twist in his
painting that in the background,
he says something about what else
was going on the lives of the map,
and deals with a sailor
and this woman is waiting
for her husband to come back.
This is my scroll, my scroll
of Esther that is actually
in the collection of
the Library here.
And, when I did this scroll, I, it's
interesting how the text developed
through the works that I work here.
I used a scribe to do the
writing, and I surrounded it all
around with text, with images.
Here, I used a woman scribe, but
you could see, like, in the window,
in the panel to, I would
say that would be your left,
where you see King
Ahasuerus wakes up at night.
And, the images around his room
are what actually took place.
So, this is Haman there sitting and
listening to Bigthan and Teresh,
and then [foreign language].
You have Haman leading
Mordecai on the horse.
And, also there's the gallows in
the door between the two guards
as a sign to what is
going to happen next.
This is from a different
scroll that I did.
Like, my, the scribes
that write the text
to send the messages
out, I give them glasses.
I mean, they didn't have
glasses at the time, but.
Here, this is like the scene where
Haman falls on the, on Esther's bed.
She was a very wise woman.
She had no power, no property,
but she understood men.
And so, she made sure
when it came to Haman,
when Haman gets drunk,
he gets into trouble.
And, that's when Ahasuerus walks
into the room and sees Haman falling
on her bed, and off he goes.
This is really an interesting
painting.
This is a painting that was done by
Paulo Coelho, and it's a painting
about a Jewish merchant during
the period where of Passover
that the stories with
the blood, the actually.
So, I took this image, and if you
know in the scroll of Esther, too,
it's the end of it
becomes very, very violent.
So, I used the image at the bottom
to paint a scene of violence
where they are breaking
into the home.
These are pages from the scroll
that I just completed now.
It's the longest scroll
of Esther ever done.
It's 54 feet long, and
I'm going to take it
to the Guinness Book of Records.
And, these are some of
the images that I did.
I painted the two characters of
Bigthan and Teresh being hung
and gave them red outfits like ISIS.
Here, this is when Ahasuerus wakes
up in the middle of the night,
so I put my two doggies,
[inaudible],
lying next to Ahasuerus's bed.
I gave them gold beds.
At home, they have plastic
beds, but this way I made sure
that they will become, they
will stay with us forever.
This is the image of Haman
leading Mordecai through the town.
These, now, we're getting to
the subject that I was planning
to talk about, and these are
sources from my visual images.
This is from Egyptian tombs, so
you can see the different animals
that are used, both in
Genesis and in Exodus.
This is from a Syrian wall relief
that I used also for my visuals.
Here, when I painted Noah's
ark, I looked at this image.
It's a monsoon flood.
Now, from an Indian manuscript.
This is, now we're getting into
my preliminary studies of the book
of Genesis, and the image on the top
is God asking Cain why did his face
fall down, meaning why did
he, why does he look upset.
So, I dropped his face down.
See on the top left corner.
This is Enoch walking with God.
This is my images, my
preliminary studies for Genesis,
the six days of creation.
So, I did more than one version.
Actually, this project that I
did, I started it as a result
of my wife's second round
with cancer where the doctor.
She went to a bone
marrow transplant,
and the doctors they played God.
So, I figured if they can play God
and God could play God,
so I can play God, too.
So, I created.
That's how I got myself involved
with illustrating the Bible.
And, my thought was, you know,
instead of feeling sorry for myself,
to do something productive.
This is the expulsion
from the garden.
And, that's what I thought you
seeing here the ark how I used the
same element of the water that I
took from the Indian miniature.
Here, I compared, this is
also a preliminary study.
I compared the two buildings
that are in the book of Genesis.
One is God's, by God's
will is the ark,
and against his will
is the Tower of Babel.
So, I painted it like an antenna,
a communication center today.
These are all the characters
from Shem, Ham, and Japheth that
and all the way to Abraham.
So, I just made them
up as we went along.
This is the covenant
between Abraham and God.
This is the Akeda, the
sacrifice of Isaac.
This is Jacob's ladder.
This is Joseph in the pit,
and it's really interesting.
When you look at the two motives
of the two tales of Joseph
in the pit and the Akeda.
It's very interesting because
the motives are exactly the same.
In both places, there's a lie.
Here we have an animal.
Jacob asks the sons how did Joseph
die, and they, then he asks them
if an animal killed him, and they
say yes, but they're lying to him.
Here, Abraham lies to Isaac
when Isaac asks him they don't
have anything to sacrifice.
"What are we going to sacrifice?"
And, Abraham knows he's
going to sacrifice him,
but he says, "God will provide."
So, that's the lie here.
In both cases, we have another
animal that gives its sacrificed.
Here's the ram.
And, here is the goat that they use
for to cover the coat
of many colors.
Here, we have the Midianites
that end
up buying Joseph, and
we have foreigners.
And, here we have the youth
that came along sitting behind.
Here, they go up the mountain,
and here Joseph is in the pit,
and Jacob says to the
sons that he will go
to the underworld to look for him.
So, it's really interesting.
Both tales deal with breaking
basic rules, basic godly rules
that the firstborn gets the
birthright, and in both cases,
both parents give it
to somebody else.
And, the, and so it's real
interesting that the two tales are,
have the same motifs in them.
Here, I did a page of animals
in the book of Genesis.
This is the pages from Genesis.
I just wanted to show you how I, so
I did all these preliminary studies,
and then I sit with my calligrapher
and we decide page after page.
This is really an interesting
page because here there's a short,
mythological tale about the sons
of God that come down and mate
with earthly women,
and God is worried
that they're going to live forever.
So, he limits their
lives to 100 years.
So, I give them a Canaanite burial.
This is, you can see the
development of the flood
where here the ark
is coming towards us
where before it was
like going across.
Here I made the page
again with characters,
and the one in the bottom
right is how they spread
around the Mediterranean Basin.
This is, again, the image of
the ark and the tower of Babel.
So, you see, I do do
everything twice.
I'm not lazy.
This is the covenant
between Abraham and God.
This is the Akeda.
This is when Rivka
falls off the camel.
I want to say about my
images when I paint them.
Because I painted for many, many
years the Israeli landscape,
I have a nice sensibility and
use of colors, and to create,
I bring them into the
contemporary paintings that I paint.
And, you know, through the
renaissance artists painted biblical
scenes, but they painted
the wrong landscape
and the wrong clothes
and their own setups.
So, here, I brought the landscapes
of Israel into the story.
This is Jacob's ladder.
Here, I used, when Laban goes
after, when Jacob sees Laban,
he says to him, how
come your face is not
like yesterday and the day before?
So, I have his face, I
gave him three heads.
Today, yesterday, and
the day before.
Here, I made a page of all the
dreams in the book of Genesis.
When we get to Joseph going down
to Egypt, I tried to paint it more
like Egyptian hieroglyphs, and
in the bottom right corner,
it says that before Jacob,
Joseph went to see
pharaoh, he cleaned himself.
So, I gave him a shower.
This is the last page of Genesis,
and there's a development of God
because in the first book
of, in the first tale
of Genesis, God is not forgiving.
Adam and Eve sinned, and he
kicks them out of the garden.
In the last tale of Genesis,
Joseph and the brothers return
from the land of Canaan, and they're
worried he's going to kill them.
And, he turns to them and said,
"I was sent by God to save us all
and endure what I had to endure for
the sake of keeping us all alive."
This is the page.
I also did it in English.
In English, it's about
1/3 more in length
because of the amount of words.
I also did some oil painting,
the result of my project.
These are all canvases.
Cain and Abel.
This is the book of Exodus.
So, this page, I thought
of Moses when he goes
and he sees the burning bush,
and my idea is that when we study
with a professor in the
university, they're not that smart.
But, they usually they have one
or two ideas that they try to get
into our heads, and they keep on
repeating it over and over again.
But, we don't hear it until
we're ready to hear it.
So, that's my idea of the
burning bush, that Moses passed
that burning bush many, many times
for years when he was with Jethro,
but only when he was ready
to hear God, he saw him.
And, that's when the
burning bush was on fire.
This is the gathering
at Mount Sinai.
Here, I took this image
by a [foreign language] the
heart of pharaoh hardened.
But, in Hebrew [foreign language]
means also that it was heavy.
So, I took an image from the
Book of the Dead where the heart,
if your heart was heavier
than a feather,
you didn't go to the underworld.
Here, I can, I took ideas.
When God stops the Egyptians
from chasing the Israelites
he uses first fire.
And so, fire is not a motif
in the Egyptian culture.
It's a motif in the Assyrian
culture, in the east cultures.
So, I thought, and my idea about
all these tales that wherever we are
in the Middle East, in and
around the Mediterranean Basin,
we all use the same tales.
So, here, I have the Egyptians
dying in the, drowning in the sea.
But, I also use the tale
about Marduk and Tiamat.
Tiamat is going to kill all
the lesser gods and her son,
and the lesser gods come to
Marduk and ask him to save them.
And, there's no way to save them
because nobody can kill her,
but she has seven heads.
So, he drowns one of
her heads in the lake.
She opens her mouth.
He puts a dagger in her
mouth and kills her.
When we get out of the story of
the crossing the sea, we thank God,
and we're ready to build a temple.
We haven't been to Jerusalem yet or
to Mount Sinai or any other place,
but we're ready to
build him a temple.
And, these guys, also, after they're
so pleased that they were saved,
they build the city of
Babel and bring humans
to worship [inaudible] there.
So, it's not the same story,
but there's similarities,
so I compare the two tales.
This is that we were
carried on eagle's wings.
Here, the skinny cats, cats.
The skinny cows eat the fat cows
but also Moses's crocodile eats
the crocodiles of the Egyptians.
Here, I compared the ten
plagues to ten Egyptian gods
because every time Moses comes to
pharaoh, he says, "I want to go
and sacrifice to my God,"
and he doesn't allow them.
So, if you can't feed, if
you won't let me feed my God,
I won't let you feed your gods.
Here, I compared the angel of death
to the angel that saved Isaac.
So, these are some of the pages from
Exodus that you're going to see.
These are pages from Leviticus.
These are called the menu.
These are all the animals we
can't eat, the non-kosher animals.
So, here, with leprosy, I used
images from Bruegel's lepers.
These are, I'm going to show you
one or two pages from the book
of Leviticus that I'm
working on right now.
I painted it with black and gold.
That's it.
[ Applause ]
I did pass my allowance,
but not by much.
But, I'm an Israeli, so.
>> Ann Brener: I know we all enjoyed
that wonderful talk by Avner Moriah.
And, I'm sure a lot of you have
questions, but we were thinking
that perhaps we just invite you back
into the conference
room for the display.
And, Avner will be talking
about his paintings there
with the books right before you.
So, you'll be able to ask him
any question that you like there.
So, please, let's give him
another hand, and please let's come
into the conference room.
[ Applause ]
Thank you very much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.